class has started and these students are
eager to learn despite temperatures in
the 40s there's neither air-conditioning
here nor a fan in fact there's no
electricity at the school but that
doesn't stop infra hemad our boa the 26
year old teacher loves his job and his
country he has no intention of leaving
despite most of his friends having left
to seek their fortunes in Europe he
doesn't want to go after school here
just go home and sit alone all my
friends are gone but they put it in me
to go but I'm not sure is a very good
way to go because I have my job here I
know it's a noble profession when I can
help my own people so that they don't
tomorrow and then in the future they
become something that minimize the
people going to the back way the back
way they call it here in Gambia meaning
the dangerous journey taken by Gambians
to get to Europe the village leader has
called for a meeting many here find it
important to send one of their family
members to work abroad despite the risks
involved
the villagers reckon in the last 10
years one in every five residents has
found his or her way to Europe yeah you
do the odd out in Bengali we only have
water and land but we can only do
agriculture we use our earnings to send
our people to Europe that's how it works
what problem buddy I had two offensive
oh yeah gun video the government doesn't
have a clue what's going on here how can
there be any development who wants his
child to die in a boat it's the hard
conditions that push people to leave you
buckle IIFA Holi by Mandela tease
however earlier this year there was a
democratic change of power in Gambia
after 22 years in office autocrat
President Yahya yama was surprisingly
sent packing
Adamo borrow took over the presidency
and there has been a ray of hope
ever since information minister denver
yahwah understands very well the great
expectations of young people who played
a crucial role in the political change
in Gambia he knows they're waiting to
get jobs but he's asking them to be
patient
with the big challenges that are
confronting this government you know 22
years of dictatorship it's extremely
difficult to undo that within a very
short period of time my message is for
em to exercise a little bit of patience
but and to assure them that the
government is very much concerned about
their plight and we are doing everything
humanly possible within the I mean
limited means
I mean under our command to actually
address most of their problems if not
all of them in a very within a very
short period of time but in BOM Bali
nothing has changed
bad roads and medical care are a big
problem and residents are forced to rely
on a small clinic in the village that
was built by one of their own who left
and made it to Europe a better life for
a nice house here are due mainly to
money sent by kin living abroad teacher
Ibrahim Adar boa earns just one hundred
euros a month that's not enough to
support his mother one of his brothers
has just arrived in Italy after crossing
the Mediterranean his mother hopes that
very soon he'll start sending her money
although Ibrahima would rather that his
brother remained at home being in a
democratic world you know that's what
London's like that's why people like me
want to go even if not now sooner or
later
good God must bring good
Ibrahim addabbo hopes the village gets
more support from the government
electricity and perhaps computers for
the schools would be a good start
before the race